it's time now for CBS deals this morning
some of the most popular items we've
showcased from products that could help
you relax or recharge those batteries
and all at exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Gail bass
joins us with more good morning Gail
good morning Jeff you know what I love
about these These are perfectly portable
all of them and you want to go to
cbsdeals.com now because these are
popular items that like to sell out and
I want to start with a re-athlete RC
what's great about this is those people
who are athletes those people who are
sticking to those New Year's resolutions
they're running they get sore I hike a
lot you get sore you put these on your
legs and they fit anybody of any size
you put them on your legs and they give
you compression that massage that you
want and if you want some heat on your
knee it can add heat to your knee it's
really really great it has three levels
of compression so if you know somebody
who works out and they say I'm somewhere
all the time get them to you use this to
help recharge it's like a bionic person
almost it is like The Bionic Man and
what's great is the price we have it for
31 off so you can get it for
137.99 think about it if you go to a
masseuse or something or they come to
your house it's more money than that you
this you could do every day for the cost
of one visit all right you can charge up
yourself or you can charge up your phone
oh what I love about the rest charge
comet is how great it is on the price
and what it can do and look here's my
phone this is really my phone you stick
the charger in and it comes to you free
it comes to you fully charged not free
that's my boyfriend okay
hi Mom his mom is watching and what's
great about it is it has passed through
technology so when I plug and charge my
phone at night I plug in my cable to the
rush charge Comet and then it passes
through and charges the phone when I
wake up in the morning I take my phone
with me I take this with me I leave the
cable at home does Bob have one that's
Brian has one yes
the hardest thing to do is to choose
what color you want look how portable it
is I could just put it right here yeah
in my pocket or somebody's very small
handbag when they're going out at night
and look at all the devices it works
with our price on this 30 off we have
them for 48.99 you can't beat that price
for convenience next I feel like we had
this one before but it's a it was a best
seller oh it is a best seller so get it
now if you want to get on and get on
this one I'm going to turn this on right
here oh this is the tiki tunes that
creates a mood and when you pair two of
them together and guess what today we
have buy one get one free when you pair
them together you get stereo sound but
not only does it create like this
ambient light this Ambience where you
don't have to set up candles that the
kids will knock over if you're having a
nice party on the patio I'm just going
to turn on some tunes so you can hear
how great it is so yeah play something
well I couldn't make me a playlist I did
make you a playlist by Tchaikovsky
number six Symphony Number Six that work
for you
right here trying it wait mine mine
didn't
oh that's my phone
off got it going
wow yeah it's absolutely amazing it well
you know classical will do that to you
and these are normally 99.99 49.99 we
have them for 49.99 for two of them so
you get buy one get one free which is
great so you get two for the price of
one and you create like who's not ready
for spring to have a picnic on the patio
already Maybe not today but one day in
the future The Sun Will Come Out
Tomorrow well eventually eventually Gail
thank you very much of course we
partnered with all these companies to
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head over to CBS deals dot com